because a lot of times it is either or
if a guy is boring probably couldn't
cheat if a guy if a guy could cheat he's
probably not boring yeah yeah female
nature I'll tell you what oh is one of
our cats going crazy oh okay
um uh men approaching women
um there are there are articles coming
out all the time
about guys that are checking out of the
dating Market guys that are saying you
know what they're throwing up their
hands or like you know what I can't do
this anymore I'm not messing with
American women what are your thoughts on
Western guys Western men uh checking out
of the dating Market what are your
thoughts on that I mean I understand and
it and I it was interesting when I first
started in red pill I didn't because I'm
very much Pro like family and marriage
and I was like why wouldn't men want to
get married but oh my God yeah but it's
like yeah but it's like okay the the
product like let's just say women like
you guys are the buyers for the products
are worse than ever before we're less
pure yep we're older yep
um we're less loyal and we're paid to
leave yes we're literally paid like you
could be a single mother and you're paid
to do it yup you're paid to get divorced
like so it's like even like I think men
and women are bullshitty I and this is a
lot of times yeah yeah I just I think I
agree with that cool yeah I think if you
take away the consequence for one gender
they're gonna get shittier of course yes
and it's like they say I think if men
were paid to leave I think if men were
paid to leave marriages they'd be
leaving these sexless whales oh my God
they will be gone yeah totally yeah I'll
tell you what if they were hey but
they're like not what do you think you
get the phrase it's cheaper to keep her
oh my god well listen if she's a whale
it might not be yeah I've had the exact
same thoughts about that
no like if divorce rates are higher
women file for divorce because they have
everything in the game they have the
incentive exactly yeah you're paid to do
it yeah
if I'm gonna lose half my stuff I'd deal
with a sexless marriage too yeah right
and then it's like guys are like you
know what we won't get married but then
there's common law marriage so it's like
the government is like twisted and I'm
not gonna act like I know the ins and
outs of it sure but just from the
general that I know I'm like so
basically even if guys want to have a
relationship and deal with what they
like have and they still even though
we're less we're older less pure if they
still say you know what I still want to
give it a go because I I want a woman I
don't want to be alone the government
still says no you must you must here's
the thing one of the four pillars of
feminism is the transference of
resources from men yeah to women and the
way this used to work and it it kind of
changes by the decade and so the way it
used to work if you got married and she
decided to divorce you no fault divorce
just like you said women are paid to
leave okay men started walking away from
Merit but they kept putting they kept
putting babies in women right so the
government said okay we're going to
increase the child support deadbeat dads
blah blah blah thanks to Bill Clinton
for that now guys are starting to wrap
up and they don't want to have kids with
these hoes out here so then comes the
common law marriage hey if you live for
there I think in in the state of Georgia
some guy told us if a woman is under
your roof for more than 30 days you
can't legally kick her out so so there's
that then there's common law marriage so
now guys are like no cohabitation no
relationships but you want to know how
they still transfer resources from women
to men dating apps because women aren't
paying for dating apps it's the men who
are paying for dating apps the purp the
purpose of dating apps are not to bring
happy couples together no the purpose of
dating apps is to make money women don't
pay women aren't buying Tinder gold it's
the men that are buying tender gold
right women don't pay to get into the
club you know you or I'm sorry women
don't pay to get in the club men do all
the paying so that's how so because the
it's almost as men continue to adjust to
try to dodge the long arm of of the
government law taking their resources
giving them to women now it comes to a
point I'm a guy I'm unmarried I have no
kids you want you wanna you wanna know
what my tax bill was last year thirty
six thousand dollars that's going that's
going to the single Brothers for welfare
Medicaid et cetera et cetera so even
though I am reproductively responsible
at least not that I don't know if I have
any kids out there if I do but even
though I am a reproductively responsible
man I don't have a bunch of kids I am
not married I'm not on dating apps the
government still finds a way to transfer
my resources to women yeah and that's
the thing like you guys keep paying for
a bad decisions yes so it's like like I
always say like women have no
consequences for anything nothing it's
like okay if we want to sleep around we
have birth control okay and and even if
we get pregnant off of birth control we
have abortion even if we keep the kid
we're paid to be a single mother even if
we get married were paid to get divorced
even if and I was like if we're bad with
our money there's women's shelters and
then government benefits where men are
just homeless I'm like we literally
can't make a bad decision nope and get
bail and and there's simps at the end
that's right the single mom that's right
and I I don't you know I don't
necessarily like blame simps in a way I
I do and I don't like let me ask you
this what is your definition of a simp
um I think it's like putting women on a
pedestal that like clearly don't deserve
it I think my definition of a simp and
it's to me it's very simple I was
actually going to release a short about
this the definition of a Sim is a man
who gives an undeserving woman access to
his time his energy his attention and
resources that's it doing [ __ ] for women
that they don't deserve a lot of guys
say well Donovan got Devin a boob job
Donovan bought uh you know Michael
Donovan bought Devon a pair of two
thousand dollars your ride or die there
you go she earns Devon will sit here and
tell you she has everything I've given
her she has earned but and the reason I
do for her is because she deserves it
but most guys are doing [ __ ] for women
that don't deserve it all they're doing
is giving up the butt and a lot of times
they don't even they don't even give up
the butt and they're still getting stuff
from men yeah it's unbelievable man yeah
and that's that's the and I think that's
why on like women used to like to be
courted and they don't now I think it's
because like deep down we know we ain't
[ __ ] there you go why are you doing all
that there you go why are you doing all
this extra stuff I see this all this is
why I tell I I forget which law it is I
think it's law number five of the 49
laws of sharp never treat us like a lady
and the reason why you don't treat a
[ __ ] Like lady is because [ __ ] don't
know how to act when they actually get
respect this is why women [ __ ] on men
who put them on a pedestal because in
her mind and again she's not thinking
about this she's not thinking about this
consciously it's in the back of her mind
I'm a [ __ ] hoe I [ __ ] three dudes
last week I've got two kids by two
different men I've got a tattoo of my of
the ex that Alpha widowed me and I have
sex with this sky before I go out on
dates with him yet he's calling me wife
material there's a woman cannot mentally
respect a man who is that ignorant and
oblivious to to what modern women get up
to that's why these women run these guys
through the middle well that's because
we can't trust your judgment because
clearly like
[Laughter]
I'm trying to tell you I'm trying to
tell you does he know him yeah yes and
it's like it's like how many of it like
I think how many of us are virgins
anymore we're not virgins the answer is
no yeah so it's like unless she's like a
pure virgin like you don't have to do
all that no you really don't
um so why don't so let's go back to the
original question why so men walking
away from relationships and I say this I
say this a lot
um at there there are times where I'm
giving men advice on how to deal with
modern women but if somebody told me all
right Donovan if if you had a son what
would you advise him to do in the
stadium Market my advice to my son my
brother my father whoever leave the
country leave the country you can't dude
leave the country don't move to
Australia the UK Canada or the US now
there are some feminist Hot Pockets here
and there but by and large women
overseas are they're they're just it's
just a better product out there
but then I think to myself well 99 of
men don't have the resources or the
fearlessness to move to another country
that's where I come in hey you're not
listen and a lot of guys complain oh I'm
not going to date American women blah
blah blah okay well if you're not
planning on moving overseas then shut
the [ __ ] up nobody wants to hear you
complain well
like
they're getting worse you know they're
like 20
countries
just because I'm in England like I hear
feedback from people from more like
Eastern European and other countries
yeah yeah and the women are definitely
better they're in better shape but like
of course feminism is still coming it is
it is
you can't really guarantee and even if
you take her and you bring her into the
U.S oh my God that's good yeah like like
if you a lot of guys are like I'm gonna
go to Southeast Asia I'm gonna get a
wife and bring her back here
good luck dude because listen our cult
dude our culture has it has corrupted so
many foreign women they dude they get to
the states and they end up becoming
worse than the American women because
they're in better shape they're prettier
they're younger they're like wow I'm
getting all this attention from all
these guys my husband's friends are all
in my ear about girls nights out and
people especially women cannot stand it
when there's another woman who has the
attention of a high value man that they
don't have and so what they will do is
they will attempt to sabotage that
relationship yeah come out with us for
the girls and they say your husband will
never know XYZ et cetera et cetera never
bring a foreign woman back to America it
is dude it is the biggest mistake you'll
ever make
and like I think it's two different
cultures can be hard and I think if you
like do you want to live in a different
culture away from your Fable I don't
know well that's the trade-off I just
don't know if that's practical I mean
like they could want to do it but well
well I'm just thinking about my brothers
I'm like I don't think they'd be happy
like living in no you're you're right
and that's the trade-off so listen you'd
have access to higher quality women but
you'd be separated from your home
country yeah like that's the price you
have to pay yeah listen get a passport
come back and visit your your family but
even if like I don't know where your
family you're from the Wisconsin area um
me and my brothers and sisters we all
live in different states it would be
nothing for me to move to another
country because I see my family once a
year if I'm lucky so if you think about
it from that standpoint but this is but
you're right that is an incredible price
to pay as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible